This morning, one of Hollywood's biggest power couples is calling it quits.
Media mogul Kim Kardashian filing for divorce from her husband Kanye West,...
...being seen without her wedding ring the night before filing.
One day after, Kanye was seen still wearing his wedding band.
The pair is splitting up...
...but reportedly making things as amicable as possible for their children,...
...and now looking to divide a global empire.
The superstar couple began dating in 2012 and had their first child a year later...
...with West proposing using a massive screen at an empty ballpark in San Francisco.
After recent strains on their marriage spilled into public view,...
...their divorce comes after more than a decade in the spotlight,...
...including West's ill-fated campaign for president in 2020.
Through it all, West has remained an entertainment titan.
Album sales have soared and his fashion line is starting a new 10-year deal with GAP.
This as Kardashian shifts her focus to political issues like criminal justice reform.